my dad just gave up trying to put me in
sports what did you play soccer for like
two or three seasons and actually now
that we're talking about it it makes me
think how funny those games probably
were for adults you know your kids all
hype to put all the [__] on yeah and
you're just like you're you're not gonna
listen you're just gonna go out there
and be a little [__] you're not good at
this yeah you're watching your kid
receive all this instruction from the
coach and it's like okay got it and then
they go out there
this is all magnetized to the ball and
the ref is like guys guys defense
something feel like let's spread out
here you gotta pass it before you shoot
it everyone just
farting and punch each other
safety